هو اللقاء الحادي والاربعون بين الرئيسين
الصيني والروسي على مدى عقد من الزمن
موسكو كانت مجددا خيار
لتكون اول وجهه خارجيه له بعد اعاده
انتخابه زعيما للصين
[موسيقى]
الصين اهتماما كبيرا لتطوير العلاقات
الصينيه الروسيه بحكم ان في هذا الامر
منطقا تاريخيا وبحكم اننا اكبر الدول
الجوار ونحن شركاء في التعاون الاستراتيجي
الشامل وهذا هو الوضع الذي يحدد ما يجب ان
يكون بين بلدينا من علاقات وثيقه
كثيره للملفات على جدول مباحثات الرئيسين
بما فيها تلك التي تشغل العالم مؤخرا بسبب
الحرب في اوكرانيا
في اوكرانيا وبالطبع ستكون لدينا
الامكانيه لبحث المساله ندرك تماما انكم
تنطلقون من مبدا العداله واحترام اسس
القانون الدولي ومبادئه وانتم تعلمون اننا
دائما من على عمليه التفاوض سنناقشه كافه
هذه المسائل ومقترحاتكم والتي نحترمها
باهتمام كبير تتعامل موسكو مع هذه الزياره
فنتائجها يمكن ان تجلب حلولا اقتصاديه
لروسيا تخفف عنها عبء العقوبات الغربيه
يتركز الاهتمام على الاستثمارات في قطاع
الطاقه والصناعه والخدمات اللوجستيه اضافه
الى ما يمكن ان تخرج به القمه من اتفاقيات
في المجال العسكري التقني لا سيما محاجه
البلدين الى التقنيات العسكريه المتبادله
في ضوء ازدياد حده التوتر قرب حدودهما
القمه تاتي على خلفيه تصعيد في اللهجه من
قبل موسكو وفيجين اللتين ترفضان الهيمنه
الغربيه في العالم واستمرار الحرب في
اوكرانيا اما مبادره السلام الصينيه
فحظوظها في النجاح معدومه لان الغرب لا
يريد عمليه سلام كتب عليها صنعت في الصين
والايجابي فيها ان الصين خرجت بفضلها من
خندقها لتقدم نفسها ايضا قوه دبلوماسيه
دوليه
على المستوى الجيوسياسي لم يخفي بوتين وشي
في تصريحات استبقت القمه رغبتهما في رؤيه
عالم اكثر تكافئا متعدد الاخطاب لا يتجزا
فيه الامن تحكمه الشرعيه دوليه وليس هيمنه
غربيه تتوجه انظار منافسي روسيا والصين
الى مخرجات القمه يوم الثلاثاء لاسيما ما
يتعلق منها باوكرانيا وبافاق التحالف
الروسي الصيني الذي لا حدود له كما يؤكد
بوتين
الجزيره موسكو